one of the chances it can be really
being the next superpower well I mean
obviously they were really really what
over a million people you're going to be
taking very seriously whether in terms
of trade resources agricultural demand
the views that India has an
international negotiations niggas be the
main variables will be how well India
succeeds with kids 3 e's expansion yes
that's definitely in the cards a lot of
growth hitting rid of explosion and
trying to do to promote inclusion that
into a whole number of areas like mixing
water problems because the world of
water like that some housing pics and
access to employment which India is
trying to do very hard with the energy
and I think doing very well so expansion
explosion and excellent and when the
major themes of this meeting has been
the real need for better education more
accessible to people and producing
better product so yes India will be a
superpower I'm so important how really
much of the determinant player how able
to take advantage of its own strengths
will depend on how well it sticks to the
determination to achieve these goals